hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video ihr seht schon komplett andere
locations vor jalousien
ich wollte das ganze video einfach
draußen aufnehmen weil zentrale 27 grad
und in meinem zimmer sind gefühlte 7000
gratis wegen sitze ich jetzt gerade hier
draußen ich hoffe das stört jetzt
niemanden von euch das thema des
heutigen videos ist es nett weil ich
habe euch gesagt dass er dort fragen in
form von videos zu senden soll ich werde
etwas denke ich demnächst öfter machen
deswegen ein mainz entnahme ist
wir fangen aber direkt schon mit der
ersten frage alles klar liga auf jeden
fall dank für eine korrekte einsendung
kollegen danke auch für deine einsendung
ist echt eine ultra wente frage die man
auf jeden fall nicht bei google direkt
herausfinden kann wieso lässt in den
videos immer solche pausen und guckst in
den pausen schöpften die kamera
das fragen mich so viele auch andere
youtuber wie durch das mache und es ist
irgendwie so meinen style wenn ich
irgendwie was mache und lava da kommt im
hintergrund wenn dann irgendwas
komisches passiert dann weiß ich im
schnitt okay das war etwas komisches
matti musik aus und mache sie umrahmen
und blau ist halt irgendwie so mein das
habe ich jetzt wahrscheinlich gerade
wieder gemacht oder das ist halt einfach
so mein stil in diesen pausen atme ich
dann und dann wenn ich jetzt so laber
landes ist eine scheiße so eine kappe
sowie es wieder so gemacht
also mich würde interessieren video dazu
gekommen bist youtube videos zu machen
das habe ich doch tatsächlich schon
unsere auf beantwortung zwar war es
einfach irgendwann den herbstferien oder
so dass ich langeweile hat und mir
gedacht wenn die irgendwie ein game
zocken dazu labert dann müsste ich das
auch hinkriegen und letztendlich ist
eigentlich nur aus langeweile entstanden
in welchem land bist du am liebsten ich
bin am liebsten grad übrigens im
hintergrund ist gerade eine
wasserfontäne also falls euch ich
pinkeln nicht gerade nebenbei oder
sobald sich das für andere ich bin
wirklich am liebsten in deutschland weil
einfach alles geregelt ist aber so von
temperaturen denke ich amerika so los
angeles san francisco wäre das perfekte
für mich möchte später unbedingt in
london wo
einfach weil es nicht zu weit von zu
hause weg ist und das gespürt hatten
hast du alles so gemacht ich habe an
sportarten schon alles gemacht ich hab
alle möglichen schwimmabzeichen ich habe
glaube ich fünf sechs jahre tennis
gespielt drei jahre basketball sieben
jahre fußball und derzeit mache ich nur
noch so joggen ein bisschen fitness
studio ab und zu schwimmen sondern
mischling weil bei mir von der uni ist
es halt so dass ich keinen festen
stundenplan habt mich jede woche
wiederholt sondern jede woche ist anders
aufgebaut deswegen kann ich keinen
verein sport machen weil es einfach
zeitlich nicht befristet werden
luca was ist ein aktuelles lieblingslied
mein aktuelles lieblingslied ist mein
buch ich gegen wieso unser neues ding
wieder gang namens teil oder so dass man
zu diesem lied was eigentlich im
ultralangen jetzt einfach diesen running
man macht dann kannst du eigentlich nach
münchen oder hast du schon mal in
münchen ich war schon öfters sind
münchen ich finde die stadt auch ultra
cool wenn ich das nächste mal da bin
werdet ihr es sicherlich erfahren die
letzten male dass ich da war glaub ich
wegen dem bayern 3 radiointerview dann
bin ich mal durchgefahren auf dem weg
nach österreich familie von mir kommt
aus tübingen
deswegen haben wir da dann irgendwie
auch uns in münchen mal getroffen oder
irgendwie so auf jeden fall war ich da
schon ein paar mal und ich mag die stadt
aber es ist wie ein bisschen zu weit weg
wie würdest du deine packen denn wenn du
ins hättest erstmal will ich mich ultra
freuen weil ich ein alpaka hätte und wie
es nennen würde wüsste ich glaube ich
noch nicht ich mache das ja immer von so
ein paar sachen also ich würde auf jeden
fall nicht einfach ihn nennen oder so
das wäre da nicht ein bisschen zu
einfallslos ich weiß nicht ich glaube
ich wird dem linken verrückten namen
geben wie king julien der zweite oder
irgendwie so war das wäre glaube ich
dass es witzig soll entgegen juli kommt
und blogger angeritten wie es heißt
partie mit minecraft aufgehört weil
gleichzeitig die krippe hier mitgemacht
ich muss sagen dass ich in letzter zeit
so youtube für mich irgendwie neu
entdeckt habe und zwar habe ich es eine
sehr lange zeit lang so gemacht dass ich
das gemacht habe worauf ich bock hatte
und dann habe ich mich aber irgendwie in
die schiene reindrängen lassen dass ich
nur noch das gemacht habe was mir gesagt
wurde was ich machen soll und dadurch
habe ich den spaß an der ganzen sache
verloren habe lange zeit mit dem
gedanken gespielt mit youtube komplett
aufzuhören ich bin ja nicht abhängig
davor nicht machen das ja nicht
hauptberuflich wie 100 prozent aller
anderen youtuber heutzutage und dann
habe ich aber für mich irgendwann so den
schlussstrich gezogen habt dann so
gesagt so jan luca
jetzt auch mit dem was dir nicht mehr
gefällt nur noch wirklich die sachen
hoch die dir gefallen dann habe ich mir
ein ablaufplan gemacht und auch dort so
viele ideen rein geschrieben die ich
hatte das waren 30 verschiedene spiele
50 verschiedene reald video ideen
formate zum beispiel dass gerade hier
ist der chat fragen beantworten das eine
sache davon die ultra feiere ich feiere
snap chat ich für euch und ich war zu
warten zu beantworten deswegen ist es
mir super coole kombi und das ist der
grund warum ich mit minecraft aufgehört
habe mir macht es momentan wirklich
nicht mehr so viel spaß wie es mir
damals gemacht hat deswegen kommt
derzeit nur noch einmal die woche und
meistens auch einigen gameplay wo ich
dann im hintergrund bleibe oder so aber
ich will gar nicht sagen dass mir das
spiel auch in zukunft keinen spaß machen
wird weil ich denke minecraft bekommt
immer wieder neue updates und das ist
mir eben vielleicht irgendwann wieder
spaß machen wird so dass es täglich
kommt will ich alles nicht ausschließen
aber zusammenfassen kann ich sagen ich
habe damit aufgehört weil ich mir gesagt
habe youtube broadcast hält macht das
war auf dem bock hast und er treibt
immer mehr bock auf andere sachen stets
um mal wieder ein paar große spiele ich
finde es über 40 wie du dich erschrecke
ich mich zwar auch recht voll cool rose
spiele stehen auch auf der liste drauf
von sachen die ich noch machen möchte
auf jeden fall ich meine letzte große
spiele kamen alle ultra gut an meinen
die sachen nicht ins länder und pfeifen
als freddy sam ich habe jetzt überlegt
demnächst mal den neuen teil von einst
verließen zocken also 56 78 17
und wenn ihr ideen für irgendwelche
spieler habt schreibt es mir gerne unten
in die kommentare
aber kommt demnächst lacht würde ich mal
wieder dann kann es kissen das shirt
wird so irgendwo zwischen 24 und 29 euro
liegen
es wird einmal in schwarz weiß und in
weiß schwarz also quasi ein rundes kids
mit dem diese kommt denn jetzt auf
einmal so viel wind ihr mann es ist ja
noch einmal los mit der welt dass wir in
schwarz-weiß geben und in weiß schwarz
also diese hundekissen und ein genaues
datum haben wir noch nicht es wird
allerdings nicht mehr so lange dauert
also ich denke jetzt vielleicht alle
es ist noch ein monat aber ich kann und
nichts genaueres sagen aber das werde
ich noch in videos und twitter und
snapshot und überall noch verkündet ihr
müsst wissen wir nicht mehr eis bestelle
bestellt ich mir zehn milliarden
verschiedene kugel niemand spaziert ella
after eight vanille
das war's und wenn wir noch amaretto ich
es aber auch wirklich sehr oft bei der
eisdiele einfachen spaghetti eis oder
trinken vanille milchshake oder so also
ich bin jetzt nicht unbedingt zu dieser
highstreet der taiwan altena waffe
braucht ihr kicktipp das ist genau das
lässt sich auch von der weltbank dass
ich meine besten gedanken darüber macht
was da ist
verschiedene russen wodka wort genug
würdest du mich mal ein postfach
exakt ich wollte mal ein postfach
eröffnen allerdings war dann die studio
71 fantreffen convention in wien und da
habe ich insgesamt zwei riesige tonnen
voll mit seinen geschenken bekommen
allein auf einem fan treffen und ich
weiß nicht wie es aus atem würde wenn
sie ein postfach machen würde
ich müsste eine poststelle mieten ich
feiere euren support und ich werde auch
wollt ihr das überhaupt dass ich die
ganze sache neben dem video vorstelle
also an gehabt vielleicht eine halbe
stunde wo ich so alle sachen raus wurde
die ihr mir so geschenkt hat als wenn
man mit einer bewertung wenn ihr das
haben wollt also dass in echt viele
krasse sachen dabei so 40.000 ukulelen
und 30.000 sie mir geschenkt wurden ich
denke dass mit dem postfach lasse ich
erst mal unterschied die idee beiseite
weil das viel zu krank werden würde
bitte tötet mich ja ich bin dumm ist das
hält ja das ist eine sache die ich mir
tatsächlich auch immer denke warum bin
ich so dumm und hässlich was studierst
du eigentlich bei mir ist es mit dem
studium und allgemeinen relativ privaten
informationen sodass sich die biber aus
meinem öffentlichen youtube legen so ein
bisschen raus halten möchte also es gibt
viele youtuber die weiß man alles was
sie für ein auto fahren was sie für eine
wohnung haben wie sie mit nachnamen
heißen ich melde mich weiß man auch viel
gar keine frage weil ich einfach videos
mal von meinem leben mit euch teilen so
ein bisschen als ihr wissen zum beispiel
hat heute gleich was meine lieblings
eissorten sind und was mein
lieblingslied ist derzeit und so was
allerdings mache ich dann klaren kanten
und zwar auf der linken seite stehen
alle sachen die ihr wissen dürfen
beispielsweise lieblingssorte
lieblingslieder und auf der rechten
seite stehen alle sachen so nachname
wohl dass ich für ein auto fahre und hat
unter anderem auch was ich studiere ich
hoffe ihr versteht das ich bin ich so
wie jeder andere youtuber alles von sich
preisgibt ich denke dass trotzdem viele
leute vieles über mich wissen das
beunruhigt mich auch aber sage ich
vielleicht wenn ich fertig bin mit dem
studium den adia habe ich gern hat der
liebe gott stück alles klar
ich meine ist das heute die folge wo
alle leute auf russisch und schweiz
österreichischen patienten können laut
auf was dann bin ich nämlich jetzt auch
ganz schnell mal weg ist nicht böse die
frage bekomme ich sehr oft weil die
leute halt meine gaming videos ich denke
auch luca mann der ist total scheiße in
dem spiel machte hat extra das entwickle
ich so schlecht die sache ist ich bin
ein sehr ungeduldiger allerdings auch
gleichzeitig tollpatschiger mensch und
bei mir kommen sehr häufig
flüchtigkeitsfehler deshalb wenig
endspiel zocker wie beispielsweise an
ferrari und ich bin erst gut und dann
mache ich einen fehler damals den fehler
immer und immer wieder um die frage zu
beantworten ich tue nicht so als wäre
ich dumm ich bin auch nicht dumm ich bin
nur ein bisschen tollpatschig und ich
kann wirklich nicht zocken schafft was
handwerker allerdings angeht zwei linke
hände und was zocken angeht auch das
einzige was ich sagen kann es gibt und
davon mache ich keine videos auf einem
kanal hommels aber auch schon zur
letzten frage weil das video schon ultra
grip
den max alles klar also ich kann gar
nicht mit den augen arbeiten weil
irgendwie komme ich habe jemals eine
rote scheiße von ihrer brille weil ihr
so drückt auf der nase ich weiß dann
immer also die die sache ist auch hier
sollten snaps geschickt werden und
innerhalb von zwei oder drei minuten kam
so 22.000 snaps an
seid ihr krank ist meine story werden
immer so an die hunderttausend mal
geklickt oder 24 stunden aber betrachtet
ihr denn so aus ok davon 60 prozent
irgendwas mit tomatensaft und 39 was
hast du eigentlich gegen tomatensaft nur
ein prozent waren vernünftige fragen die
habe ich jetzt hier drangenommen naja
mir hat es spaß gemacht ich hoffe ihr
habt einiges mehr michael ach so das
war's mit lady auf ein technisch
bewertung freund wollte so etwas noch
mal öfter whatever keine ahnung folgt
mit chat mehr reden und ich lasse jetzt
in ruhe tschüss